hi guys just checking in with all of you
who are concerned about me all as well
britney spears breaking her silence my
family has been going through a lot of
stress and anxiety lately so i just need
a time to do but don't worry i'll be
back very soon the singer returned to
social media tuesday sharing that video
to instagram assuring fans she's doing
fine amid allegations that she's being
held against her will at a health
facility britt also posted a lengthy
caption in it she calls the rumors crazy
and encourages her fans to avoid
believing everything they read and hear
quote i am strong and stand up for what
i want what I need right now is a little
bit of privacy to deal with all the hard
things that life is throwing my way you
can hold on to family when you go
through hard times like that the video
is seemingly a response to the hashtag
free Britney movement which has exploded
online in the past few days Britney fans
have flooded her family social media
pages with questions about what is
really going on with the pop star after
she recently entered a health facility a
source previously told et that Britt
decided to seek treatment due to the
tremendous stress she's endured as her
dad Jamie Spears battled a
life-threatening health crisis which
lines up with what she said in the new
video message my family has been going
through a lot of stress and anxiety
lately Brittany also postponed her album
and put her Britney domination show in
Las Vegas on indefinite hold before it
even began
there's finished days where it's been
harder for me than other days my
philosophy is just take each day at a
time after it went public that Britney
was in treatment the host of the
Britney's grand podcast claims they
received quote an anonymous tip from a
credible source that the toxic singer is
being held against her will in the
health facility and thus the free
Britney hashtag was born fans who
believe the podcast claims protested in
front of West Hollywood City Hall on
Monday night to support Britney Petey
was on the scene and spoke to test
Barker and Barbara gray the creators of
the podcast the duo isn't down with the
fact that Britney has been in a
conservatorship for nearly 12 years I
also certainly hope that any individual
who has any kind of an actual
section two the woman Britney Spears
will be brave enough to speak out about
what has actually been going on for over
a decade and and if I may add and if I
may add any individual who feels that
it's appropriate for Britney Spears to
be in this situation any individual who
feels that Britney Spears does not have
the wherewithal to do things like use a
phone without permission or drive a car
without permission I would really wonder
why they feel it's appropriate for her
to be touring the world for the last
three years and to have put out three
huge albums and to have had a very
successful Vegas residency there has
been no corroboration that Britney went
into treatment against her will or is
being held in the facility ét learned
that the 37 year old singer briefly left
her treatment facility last week to get
her hair done at a salon in LA and she
left again on Sunday to spend time with
her boyfriend Sam